the libs are threatening to murder us
again
after weeks of top democrats all the way
up to the president calling republicans
fascists terrorists comparing us to
al-qaeda encouraging people to kill maga
voters
a new death threat from the libs has
just dropped this one care of democrat
senator maisie hirono
when i hear my colleagues talking about
how
you know it should be states rights or
government should not be telling us what
to do
the word hypocrites
it doesn't even go
far enough
to call them out on what they're doing
this is an outright attack on women in
this country that is how i see it that
is how more and more women and those who
support
our right to make decisions about our
own bodies that is how we see it and why
because that's what's
happening madam president
i yield the floor but clearly you know
this is
a um
literally call to arms
in our country
yield the floor
literally
it's literally it's not figuratively a
call to arms from macy hirono lest there
be any confusion maisie hirono is
calling on her fellow democrats to
literally
pick up guns and shoot us
that's what that means when you say this
is literally a call to arms i know it's
difficult for most conservatives to
believe because conservatives generally
are nice people who just want to go back
to the good old days when ronald reagan
and tip o'neill they'd fight all day and
then they'd go get a drink after work
even though those days never existed by
the way it didn't happen those men were
bitter enemies who rarely ever even
spoke and tip o'neill considered ronald
reagan evil his words publicly
we keep telling ourselves nice stories
about norms and getting along and
meeting in the middle
but it just doesn't happen and it
probably never did
the democrats are going to be carting us
off to the gulags and we're going to be
making jokes about what the press would
say if the situation were reversed can
you imagine if we were recording them
off to the gulags maisie hirono is going
to be lining us up against a wall with
an uzi in one hand and an ak-47 in the
other and we're going to be giggling as
somebody says well so much for the
tolerant left
we just don't have the political
imagination
maybe we think a little too highly of
ourselves we think no one could ever
really hate us no one could ever really
wish us harm
we just can't come to terms with the
fact that these people
genuinely do not like us and do not want
us around i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from the drummer's
workshop at norm's music hey what's
going on i haven't seen that commenter
for a while uh for the biden
administration james taylor should have
called his song brimstone fire and rain
that's a really great point that's true
oh i'm gonna see brimstone and fire and
rain because you've got drag kids
marching down at the new york fashion
show and you're transiting
three-year-olds and killing all the
babies and i'm probably never gonna see
this again because we're very likely
going to be
uh
given all of the gross evil going on in
the country when you want to protect
yourself with all this kind of craziness
you really got to check out birch gold
right now text knolls to 989898
the biden administration has recently
announced its plan to hire 87 000 new
irs agents in 2023 many of whom will be
bearing arms as they shake you down for
your money you need to secure your
savings in a tax sheltered account now
and birch gold can help you do just that
birch gold group helps you hold gold and
silver in a tax sheltered retirement
account to protect you from big
government trying to take all your
wealth plus throughout history gold has
always been your best hedge against
inflation a diversified savings can
protect you from downturns in the market
if you have a 401k or ira that is
underperforming just text knowles canada
wles to 98 98 98 and you can convert
that into an ira in precious metals
right now birch gold group has an a plus
rating with a better business bureau
countless five-star reviews and
thousands of satisfied customers text
knolls to 98 98 98 and birch gold will
send you a free info kit on diversifying
into gold tax free take the necessary
steps to hedge against inflation today
protect your hard-earned money get your
free info kit by texting knolls to 98 98
98 now
they don't like us guys they don't they
really don't like us i think we like
them much more than they like us and we
tolerate them much more than they
tolerate us and we're willing to live in
a country with them much more than
they're willing to live in a country
with us
they're they're calling us terrorists
they're calling us nazis they say we
need to be treated the same way osama
bin laden was treated they're saying
that that the libs need to pick up arms
this is a call to arms against two
against us they're saying that they need
to kill the maga movement okay they need
to kill mega voters they're saying
going back years now that democrats need
to confront republicans in public and
push back on them and say you're not
wanted here
that's what maxine waters said that that
democrats need to go to republicans
homes
and scream outside their homes and then
they did that
then one of them tried to kill brett
kavanaugh
and all the while we say oh well it's
craziness you know we just need to
return to standards and norms trump
shouldn't be so mean he needs to stop
tweeting about mika brzezinski's face
guys they're they're talking about
killing us
they they say in explicit terms we're
gonna we're going to kill you and then
you know what they do for eight months
they burn the country down and they kill
us okay and blm and antifa riot and they
killed dozens of people
and republicans still don't get it and
we still say well you know they've kind
of got a point about january 6th i mean
after all you know that the smiley guy
from florida did kind of move nancy
pelosi's lectern yeah they're talking
about killing us guys stop comparing
these two things
there is no comparison here okay
we need well you know listen if we wield
political power
to in any way enforce the law and
justice well that will make us no
different from the democrats who are
completely disregarding the law and
wielding the government to attack us no
that won't
those two things are not the same at all
actually if we don't wield political
power that the people happily give us on
occasion to some small degree then
they're going to ship us off to the
gulags like they're promising to do like
they're already talking about okay we
need to wield political power you are
seeing some people get this
right a handful of people i'm thinking
of greg abbott down in texas
greg abbott in texas he says hey stop
flooding the country with illegal aliens
hey biden start enforcing your border
policies and what does biden and the
democrats say they say no actually
mass illegal migration is our strength
we need
even more millions of people to come
across each year we you should count
yourself lucky that you've got all these
foreign nationals flooding into your
state and so what does abbot do he says
okay you think that way i'm going to
ship all the illegal aliens up to your
cities
so we've had since since joe biden took
office we've had about 4.2 million
illegal border crossings it's an amazing
number 4.2 million
okay
democrats say that's wonderful that's
great enjoy it texas enjoyed arizona
greg abbott sends
five thousand
ten thousand illegal aliens nothing not
a not a drop of a fraction of an iota in
the bucket of illegal immigration just
this year
and the democrats say oh my gosh this is
a strain on our resources this is an
attack on our democracy this is so
inhumane oh my gosh you can't do that so
abbott says what are you talking about
i'm giving you
barely a hint of a cent of your own
medicine
and you're you're acknowledging you're
admitting that that you've just been
attacking us the whole time to weaken
our states it's not just abbott it's
governor of arizona and now it's ron
desantis ron desantis is ratcheting it
up a notch
a ron desantis has just sent two plane
fulls of illegal aliens to martha's
vineyard
which i just
i just adore it
especially because you know i co-host a
podcast with senator ted cruz called the
verdict podcast and for weeks now maybe
months on on the show
i've asked senator cruz i've said what
are we supposed to do about illegal
immigration why don't we ever do
anything why don't we we just let the
libs take advantage of us
and
senator cruz said
not only do we need to send illegal
aliens to dc in new york he said i want
them to go to martha's vineyard i want
them to go to nantucket i want them to
go to all the really nice fancy places
that the lib's vacation in and i thought
okay that's a funny political line but
how are you going to do it senator cruz
actually took it further he introduced
legislation to relocate illegal aliens
to these places obviously democrats
control the senate it doesn't go
anywhere
but the states
could always do this sort of thing and
now governor ron desantis has picked up
that baton and said okay actually that's
a really good idea and i do have control
of florida so that's what he's done
this according to
uh desantis's communications director
florida can confirm the two planes with
illegal immigrants that arrived in
martha's vineyard today were part of the
state's relocation program to transport
illegal immigrants to sanctuary
destinations absolutely love it make
them face
the consequences that they inflict on us
there was a tweet by chris hayes i have
it right i just pulled it up right
before the show started
chris hayes says
that it is
deeply sick
and dehumanizing to fling human beings
somewhere vindictively
this is chris hayes from msnbc his whole
twitter timeline
furious about this desantis policy
meanwhile nbc news reported not so long
ago
that joe biden is also flinging those
illegal aliens around
the only difference is that joe biden
was flinging those illegal aliens around
not to the blue cities necessarily but
all around the country
again that's not daley wire reporting
that that's not breitbart news that's
not some far right wing that's nbc news
the democrats are already doing that
to say nothing of the fact that they're
flinging
they're flinging
non-americans over the border into
america because they think it'll give
them a permanent electoral advantage
they're doing that they've been flinging
millions of people around
opportunistically and vindictively for
years and then the minute that a
republican sends
one busload two airplanes full they say
this is outrageous no i don't think so i
think this is barely even
a little tiny taste of your own medicine
and this is what republicans need to
start doing
okay republicans
need to start
showing democrats the consequences of
their actions
it
the democrats are never going to stop
unless they feel the consequences of
their actions but if they get away
scot-free if republicans adopt this
loser mentality that they've had for at
least 20 years now if not longer
sort of well you know the democrats
they're upending all of our traditions
and way of life but you know
we can't do anything about that we just
need to lose with dignity come on
look and frankly illegal immigration
it's an act of love that's that's the
jeb bush line it's an act of love it's
it's not no no human being is illegal
they sound like the democrat light okay
well then we're always gonna lose
we gotta we've got to
we've gotta show democrats that they
can't just get away with this stuff and
they will they're already losing their
minds new york chicago washington dc
all the pundits they're losing their
minds over this keep it up keep it up
good job governor desantis let's get
some more plane loads let's get some
more bus loads let's get every other red
state governor to do the very same thing
maybe then we'll have a shot
at at regaining a little political power
go after them on every front go after
them on every single front you know
right now the big attack on
conservatives
is over the
great threat to our democracy that's why
they're calling us fascists and nazis
and saying that our very presence poses
an existential threat to our sacred
democracy and our republic
why because people are raising questions
about the 2020 election which was
obviously rigged it was totally rigged
they changed all the election rules
everybody knows it the democrats know it
too they published a piece in time
magazine bragging about it it's just
you're not allowed to acknowledge it
they're allowed to celebrate it you're
not allowed to complain about it you're
not allowed to say that they even said
what they already said
and and furthermore
when democrats lose elections
when they obviously lose elections when
there was no rigging when there was no
major change to the voting rules
they deny it
okay obviously stacey abrams is the
great example of this and stacy abrams
now she just appeared on the view
and stacey abrams after years and years
of telling us that she did not lose the
2018 georgia gubernatorial election what
does she do she looks right in that
camera she looks you right in the face
and she says no i never said that
so this is your second run against
incumbent brian kemp for governor and
polls show a tight race especially the
poll this morning um now when you lost
in 2018
you didn't traditionally concede which i
appreciated because you cited voter
suppression
are you confident that this will be
a free and fair collection and uh um
sorry um election and not
a repeat performance of what happened
before so i appreciate the the question
and the framing i have never denied that
i lost i don't live in the governor's
mansion i would have noticed
and there is this clip that's going
around and it shows me saying that we
won and what i was referring to was that
we won in terms of communities that were
long left out of the electoral process
right finally participated in 18 at
outstanding numbers right
but i
i'm not delusional so
just so that's clear
so so hold on she's saying no no i never
said that i that i won
okay there's this clip going around
where i i say multiple times that i won
but i didn't mean that i won you know
the election i meant that i won
you know uh some polite conversation
from different people that campaign i
know i meant that i won in the sense
that i lost i didn't mean when did i
hold on could we just watch the clip
i saw that there was a challenge with
our voting system in the state of
georgia i never denied the election i do
have one very affirmative statement
today
we won you refused to concede and say
that you lost do you stand by that
decision today absolutely the election
was not fair the process was not fair
was the election in georgia statewide a
free and fair election it was not a free
and fair election but will i say that
this election was not tainted was not a
disinvestment and a disenfranchisement
of thousands of voters i will not say
that you uh notably did not concede i
did not okay you acknowledged that he
won but you did not concede correct five
months later do you still feel like
your opponent won through voter
suppression yes
georgia voters did not have their votes
counted they were not allowed to cast
votes they had their votes discarded and
it was not fair to those who filled out
absentee ballots and depending on the
county you sent it to it either was
counted or not counted assuming you
received it in time
so
not only did she say we won not only did
she say the election was bogus not only
did she say i will not concede what a
bizarre kind of splitting of hairs
yeah you're saying you're saying you
didn't win
but you didn't concede but the only
reason you wouldn't concede is because
you did win because you didn't lose and
then my favorite part is
part of that clip is when she goes on
the view and says yeah no i totally won
i didn't lose this is not totally bogus
election and then she goes back on the
view she says i never said that
it's just the outright lies it's the
it's the outright lies that you hear
from stacey abrams it's the outright
lies that you hear from karine
jean-pierre when she comes out and she
says oh biden's doing much better on the
border than trump yeah biden wants to
secure the border trump wanted to open
the border complete inversion of reality
the outright lies we're not in a
recession yeah yeah we've had two
consecutive quarters of negative gdp
growth yeah we have we're actually in
the textbook definition of a recession
no that's that's not a recession
no because we changed the definition
five minutes ago so it's not we're not
in a recession
no it's all good
it's all good here
no no what do you we never told you that
the vaccines would stop you from getting
coved what are you talking about oh yeah
there's a clip going around where we all
told you the vaccines would stop you
from getting coveted that's not real
these are not the droids you're looking
for
up is down
it's just outright lies they have to do
that
they have to do that because the the
record that the democrats have right now
on
every on every single issue in the
united states i can't name a single
issue that they've been successful on
they're losing
and and public opinion reflects that
public opinion knows that the democrats
are not doing very well so that's why
they have to lie
but the reason they can lie of course is
because we don't have a free press in
america our press is more in the bag for
the ruling regime than pravda for the
soviet union than north korean state tv
for kim jong-un it's at the very least
as in the bag
and the reason i say it's even even more
pernicious and more dangerous is because
our media technology political apparatus
is much much stronger than it ever was
in the soviet union or in north korea
in america
the the ruling class the regime the
liberal establishment
can
settle on a lie
and then
and then have the press the corporate
media report that lie and then have big
tech suppress any semi-independent
outlet that contradicts that lie and the
most notable example of this is the
hunter biden laptop story
so
the republicans find
this laptop they've got all this
evidence of crimes committed by not just
hunter biden but by the biden family up
to and including the big guy joe
there's a story run on this
video evidence of some of the crimes by
the way
published by the new york post which is
you know not in the club it's a big
outlet but it's not nearly as big as new
york times washington post nbc abc all
the outlets all the other networks
so they publish it and then
the the supposedly free and fair press
they all say nope not true russian
disinformation nothing to see here they
completely parrot the the regime line
and then big tech comes in and they
suppress the stories
that report negatively on the hundred
button laptop and they promote the
stories that say it's disinformation
you you you never saw that kind of power
in the soviet union you never saw that
kind of power in north korea state tv
that's why the crocodile tears for our
sacred free press those intrepid
journalists
in our sacred democracy
in our sacred democracy where the people
don't really get all that much of a say
in the government and most of the rules
are made by completely unaccountable
bureaucrats who can just refuse to to
follow the orders of the republican
president on the rare occasions the
republican gets into office yeah
yeah
i don't know
i don't know it sounds a little
disingenuous to me speaking of elections
john fetterman
he is the
quasi-comatose democrat who's running
for senate in pennsylvania he's running
against dr oz who is one of the worst
republican nominees i've ever seen for
any office but he's the guy we're stuck
with i guess so we're supposed to vote
for him
it's pathetic it's it's absolutely the
most pitiful race i rely on my hair for
a lot of my power okay i i do i really i
the the quaff is very important to my
sense of self and personality i'm gonna
end up pulling all my hair out because
of this stupid race because it should be
so easy to to
beat jon fetterman in pennsylvania and
the republican nominee is completely
blowing it
but at the very least dr oz just got one
concession out of john fetterman which
is john fetterman has agreed finally to
debate dr oz and this is good because as
terrible a candidate as he is will do
better in a debate than john fetterman
if for no other reason then john
fetterman is recovering from a stroke
and can't speak the english language
properly and it's he should be in rehab
right now and it's
frankly abusive of him that he is
of his campaign team that he is still
being put out on the campaign trail when
the man is obviously
not well
but this is it he's got the nomination
he's running and because dr oz is such a
weak candidate he feels that he can win
the race and he can do so while making
these very short campaign appearances
and then basically pulling a biden and
hiding in his basement while the
campaign team runs the show for him
but he has agreed now john fetterman to
appear on stage with dr oz for a debate
here's the trick
the debate's going to be october 25th
what's today today is september 15th
the election
is first week in november
so
why would they delay this debate they're
delaying the debate because of the way
that the democrats rigged the system the
democrats exploited kovid to change the
election rules and and permit and
encourage in fact widespread mail-in
ballots and an election season that is
no longer just one day it used to be
election day you showed up to the polls
you voted and that was that now election
day has turned into election week
election month it goes on for so long
how many ballots are going to be cast by
the time these two guys debate
i bet a lot of ballots are going to be
many if not most of the ballots are
going to be cast by the time they debate
so the debate won't matter john
fetterman could get up there
and
even if he completely bombs and he could
bomb because his health is not where it
should be or he could bomb frankly i
think he would have bombed the debate
long before he had these major health
problems that he's not
the brightest bulb in the pack okay he
does not really know what he's talking
about
but it won't really matter the laws
were all changed to favor democrats so
what's the answer to this
there's only one answer as far as i can
tell the conservatives need to reorder
the election laws to favor conservatives
okay and i don't think there's anything
unjust about that or wrong about that we
know that widespread mail-in ballots are
a huge opportunity for abuse
or a huge opportunity for voter fraud
barack obama told us that ten years ago
okay so you've got to cut that down
you've got to bring election month to
election day you've got to require voter
id okay i'm not i'm not saying that
you're going to go there and anytime you
see a kind of
purple haired lunatic you know in line
looks like a total liben line you kick
them off out of the polls i'm just
saying reorder the laws to be much more
fair and if the practical effect of
fairer laws with greater voter integrity
is that it favors conservatives
wonderful love that sounds great
got to play the game folks that's
politics that's always been politics
but conservatives have been convinced
over the last 20 or so years there's
something noble and dignified about
conceding the elections to democrats
i don't get it i don't get why these
people want to be such losers other than
a lack of moral clarity and cowardice
now you know when you want some clarity
when you want when you want some courage
uh you're you're gonna want to tune into
the nostradamus fantasy football team
okay because we got extreme clarity we
are crushing all the other guys right
now i'm beating all the craning code
guys i am destroying with facts and
logic my fellow daily wire hosts drew
and ben and matt and bickley okay and we
got another game coming up i don't
really know how to play fantasy football
and i've never watched an entire
professional football game but i am
winning and now i'm going head-to-head
with drew
this coming weekend whenever the
football game is played this weekend i
will be competing against drew clavin
and i am gonna win okay so make sure you
tune in root for team nostradamus
kick that ball down the field
score those goals
whatever i'm going to win it's going to
be great so make sure that you tune in
the democrats have rigged the system to
beat us one because they've changed the
election rules
two because they physically intimidate
us and they go out and they actually
physically threaten us and make a call
to arms and uh three because of the
censorship and the censorship's really
really important so what's the answer
to the censorship
you know the democrats censor
actual relevant political reporting by
conservatives and for 20 years or so the
the conservative response has been
censorship is bad i support free speech
free either you support support all all
speech or no speech oh yeah obscene
pornography totally that's a free speech
issue you have a right to it calls to
arms to destroy the american
system of government and traditional way
of life absolutely that's protected of
course none of that is protected in the
american tradition none of that is
protected by law
no the correct answer to the to the
democrat standards and norms and taboos
that result in censorship
is conservative censorship i know i know
it's an unpopular opinion i know that
people don't want to admit that but all
regimes all societies have some kind of
censorship
because all of them have standards and
taboos so the answer if conservatives
want to stop being such losers is we
need to engage in it ourselves not in
capricious arbitrary unjust immoral kind
of censorship
but in just prudent censorship
instead of today what we've got is they
they censor the truth they censor
goodness they censor beauty and they
promote
lies and evil and ugliness
we should we should do the opposite okay
we should place far more restrictions
around
most notably obscene material material
that is really really wicked and hideous
and that that is what's happening
we did just score a win thanks to
instagram instagram just censored a post
that was aimed at teaching kids about
sexual pleasure
and i don't know maybe some of the free
speech absolutists are going to say no
by golly the reason we fought a
revolution in this country was to defend
social media posts teaching little
children about sexual pleasure but
that's not my point of view i think yep
that's good censor them censor them no
free speech for them
so this is the post
this is a post on on instagram
normalizing and destigmatizing the
pursuit of pleasure sexual and otherwise
can send a strong message to children
send a strong message to children we
need to normalize it we need pleasure
centered education contrary to what some
folks assume teaching youth that sex
feels good does not cause more young
people to have sex i'm going to pause it
right there of course it does
what are you talking about
young people this would be true for
anybody for all people of all ages but
especially for young people who don't
have control over their appetites and
their actions in many cases
telling them that something feels good
telling them that this chocolate bar
over here tastes good is going to
encourage them to try it out
okay because they are competitive
creatures that just want to pursue their
their basest passions that's what it is
that's why you have education to try to
tamp that down uh this instagram account
that posted it is called the queer sex
therapy instagram account i'm shocked
totally surprised by that and this is
managed by the expansive group
describes themselves as a team of queer
therapists coaches mentors and sex
educators that broaden insight around
gender sexuality and relationships the
author of this post is leia goodman i
don't know if it's a man or a woman or
if leia's her or his real name i don't
know anymore because these people are so
deeply confused but this individual
describes him or herself as a queer
educator and uses she slash they
pronouns so this is obviously grooming
this is obviously obscene this should be
ostracized censored and these people
should probably be imprisoned
the question though that a lot of people
keep asking when they're trying to come
to a nice
nice conservative conciliatory middle
ground here well we don't want to censor
anybody we don't want to cast any
aspersions on anybody but they'll say
but why
do kids
need to see this kind of material
from the adults
from the queer therapy
group why why do the kids need to see
this that's not the right question
obviously the kids don't need to see
this the question to be asking is
why do the queer sex therapy people
feel the need to show this to children
the question is not why do kids need to
see drag queen story hour at the public
library
they don't of course
the question is why do the drag queen
story hour people feel this deep
need
to dance around in sexually provocative
clothing for little children
because they are perverts and sexual
deviants and
at the ideological level they want to
pervert the whole culture and it's much
easier to do that when you focus on kids
because kids brains are very malleable
so if you get them young and give them a
vision of the world it's more likely to
stick in the long term
and then at the physical level
they probably have weird sexual
appetites for kids right
right i i go back to this great tweet
that has gone viral from oran mcintyre
which says it's not that complicated
guys the the these people are evil and
they just want to diddle kids
and i think there's some truth to that i
think there's a broader ideological
aspect to it
that and the left has written about this
for well over 100 years
because sex is so important to people
because it's so essential to human
nature if you can
twist the way that people think about
sex you can transform the whole culture
and the way to really twist that is to
get to people at a young age i think i
think that exists i don't think that
just derives from you know some
disordered sexual desire but then i
think also a number of people who have
performed at drag queen story hour are
child molesters that's not that's not a
coincidence okay that's not just a
random accident
yeah it's true the people who are really
obsessed with talking to little kids
about sex probably have weird sexual
hang-ups when it comes to kids so the
answer to that is censor it
pass laws against it put these people in
prison
okay i think that's actually a pretty
moderate solution the democrats are
talking about shooting all of us if we
dare suggest that maybe we should kill
fewer babies a year the democrats are
talking about shooting all of us if we
if we say that maybe we shouldn't
castrate eight-year-olds the democrats
are talking about shooting us killing us
killing mega voters calling us nazis
saying we need to be treated like osama
bin laden if we consider voting for
donald trump if we consider voting for
one of the two parties in our alleged
two-party system
you're talking about killing us
okay i think at the very least we can
put child molesters in prison
and and pass laws against the grooming
and the bizarre cultural transformation
that these people are are leading
we're we're making a big mistake i think
because we all we ever talk about is the
transgender thing that's all
conservatives are focused on right now
and
for good reason because it's it's the
most radical social transformation at
least on the surface that we've ever
seen in this country not just the idea
that we need to change certain behaviors
but the claim that there's no difference
between men and women the fundamental
distinction in human nature
then men can really be women and we've
got to mutilate people and chop them up
and get rid of the girls room and let
husky hank you know walk in to the the
public swimming pool and get naked in
front of your daughter it's obviously so
radical and insane this is why this is
the dominant issue for conservatives to
be talking about and for the libs to be
pushing for that matter
i feel though that conservatives are
making a huge mistake in how we fight
on this issue
i just discussed this at the national
conservatism conference down in miami
we know that the conservative strategy
is failing we know that despite all of
our bluster and talk and obsession about
transgenderism it's not really working
maybe we win a governorship in virginia
maybe we push back a little bit in
florida but if you just look at the
progression of the law transgenderism is
completely winning it's being shrined in
law by the supreme court by the
legislatures
in schools and corporations everywhere
okay conservatives have completely lost
on this issue and i think the reason for
that is because conservatives are making
a very shallow argument the conservative
argument right now against
transgenderism is
is
science says that men and women are
different that's the argument the the
lib argument for transgenderism is
there's biological sex and there's
gender expression and those two things
are different and they can be in
contradiction with one another
okay and it's a little more complicated
because sometimes the libs will say that
there's such a thing as a biologically
female
phallus or a biologically male uterus
and that's obviously very confusing but
when when the libs are being their most
coherent they say transgenderism rests
on a distinction between sex and gender
expression
and the conservative response
is
no gender expression's not real it's
only sex it's only biology it's only x
chromosomes and
x y chromosomes and genitals and that's
all it is that's how you know sex
and i thought
no that is that actually isn't true
obviously there's such a thing as gender
expression
gender expression is
gender expression is to sex sort of like
what the soul is to the body
right it's the metaphysical aspect of
the physical thing the body's physical
the sex is physical the gender
expression in the soul are metaphysical
obviously we know this is true because
men and women behave somewhat
differently in different cultures
obviously we know this is true because
men can be effeminate
obviously we know this is true because
women can be masculine of course there
can be one's expression of sex and
gender
can be
at odds or a little little separated
from one's physical sex so what's the
answer to this i don't think the answer
is to just deny it because when you deny
it then you fall into the same
soul-denying scientism that the the libs
used to get us into this mess in the
first place
i think the way that you have to address
this is by granting yes of course
there's such a thing as gender
expression
yeah of course
and you have a duty
to bring your gender expression in line
with your sex yeah of course these two
things are distinct the symbol and the
symbolize the body and the spirit sure
you have a duty to bring them into
alignment with one another
this word duty used to be so central to
the conservative
view of the world i mean this is what
edmund burke talked about edinburgh and
the reflections on the revolution of
france he talked about that generous
loyalty to rank and sex that proud
submission that dignified obedience that
found even in servitude itself the
spirit of an exalted freedom not just
our rights and our entitlement and our
physical bodies i mean we're talking
like the the leftist materialists when
we talk that way no duty
boys
are supposed to act like boys
they're not supposed to act like girls
and girls are supposed to act like girls
and they're not supposed to act like
boys you have a duty to fulfill a role
in society because we're not
free-floating atoms we live in a society
okay we live in a political community
and we find our place in that political
community not primarily by demanding a
bunch of rights and entitlements but
through
duty and recognizing our roles and for
fulfilling those roles
which we can perceive
in the political community and from the
transcendent moral order
that's what it's about
to to quote don that the actual
conservative response on this should not
be well actually science so there are
two x chromosomes whatever it should be
the don corleone response when he's
talking to johnny fontaine johnny
fontaine says godfather i don't know
what to do i don't can't get out of my
car he says
who are you talking about you can act
like a man
what's the matter with you you can act
like a man what's the matter with you
this week barack obama's economist larry
summers said that we have a quote
serious problem with inflation but joe
biden has refused to see it that way
calling the economy fast and strong if
only we had his eyes well
we thought we would give the old man the
benefit of the doubt and applied his
fiscal policies to our daily wire merch
sale to see if it gave you a better deal
after crunching the numbers
we quickly realized no one wants to pay
8.3 percent more for anything
so instead
we're going with our gut we're cutting
prices by 40 percent across everything
in the store now you can snag a do not
comply hat
for just 18 bucks or an old glory
baseball bat hand signed by ben
shapiro's actual hands for just 150
bucks get 40 off daily wire merch during
our inflation reduction event while
supplies last go to dailywire.com shop
the sale ends sunday hurry now
then we can all go back to 30 dollar
eggs
speaking of
the transgender madness and speaking of
all this sodom and gomorrah stuff in our
country
there is a video that has gone viral
it's being reported by reuters i have
instructed my editors to blur this video
it's a video of a 10 year old drag kid
who was just the headliner of new york's
fashion week and the video is everywhere
and it's being reported on by big news
organizations without blurring his face
i don't care it's child abuse what this
this kid's guardians are doing to him is
child abuse what the media are doing to
him is child abuse and so
i at least and i encourage other
conservatives to follow suit i am gonna
i'm gonna blur this kid's face he goes
by noella mcmahor uh he's a ten-year-old
who has been convinced to become a
transgender model and activist here's
what he had to say about his starring
role at new york's fashion week
what is normal
what is normal it's 2022 no one knows
what normal is at this point
[Music]
she's believed to be the youngest
transgender model
to walk ever cool to have that title and
it shows that i actually am like
showing other showing other people and
kids that being transgender isn't bad
through her social media she wants
people to know trans kids are not
different from other kids to be doing we
we want to make sure that
we're supporting her dreams and the fact
that
we want to be an activist and be visible
for other trans kids
we know is just so important in a world
that especially right now in our current
political climate that
has so many things that are working
against her kids like her okay for those
who couldn't watch that consider
yourselves lucky uh that last little bit
there is in what looks like times square
and it's d's
whatever the the boy's name is noella is
his fake name noella's parents
quote unquote and noella's parents are
these kind of
androgynous looking people
one of whom calls
him herself d but d has some facial hair
and looks kind of like a man but i think
he's actually a woman and then this
other eunuch sort of looking person who
i think is also a woman but also is
dressing up like a boy and i remember
reading a story about this the poor
little boy's
father who now has no role in his life
and was was booted out of the family
life and
said he has no say now over all this
crazy transgender stuff
obviously this is from the the weird
lesbian
transgender whatever uh
parents you know guardians who are
abusing this child they should have no
right to even see this child they should
be in prison that this the sort of
things that they're doing to themselves
into this child should be illegal and
and all of that was true
all this stuff was illegal extremely
stigmatized until very very recently
the child certainly would have been
taken away by child protective services
even 10 years ago
if if not even more recently
but now we live in this upside down
world where
extremely sexually confused mentally ill
people are allowed to to abuse little
children and parade a little boy around
in dresses like a sexual object at the
age of 10 at a new york fashion show and
we're not only are we not allowed to
criticize that very likely this segment
will be taken down or media matters will
clip it or there will be but whatever
who cares i mean it's just it is what it
is
not only are we not allowed to criticize
it we have to celebrate it
and it just leads to this question
that is very hard for conservatives to
consider
are we the baddies
are we the baddies because i look around
at all sorts of terrible regimes around
the world
and with regimes which in many ways do
many worse things than the united states
china
russia all these you know regimes that
do bad stuff
i don't think those regimes
trot ten-year-old boys in in little
skirts down the runway
for the seal-clapping applause of of
sexual degenerates and perverts in in
new york city in the public square and
encourage all of this stuff
that's not that that sort of thing isn't
celebrated there
are we the baddies
we didn't i don't think we used to be
the baddies i think this is kind of a
recent thing but it's a really big deal
and even beyond the transgender question
the fact that you've now got the
president of the united states sicking
his own his federal law enforcement
which is acting like his kind of
personal police force to it to raid the
home of his former of his predecessor
and current chief political rival that's
pretty batty stuff that's what they do
in really badly banana republic regimes
the fact that the president is now
hiring 87 000 new irs agents some of
whom he's going to arm to go down and
shake you down for more money than
they're already taking that doesn't seem
like a good sign especially when he's
calling you fascists and saying your
very existence is a threat to the
country that seems that seems kind of
dangerous and scary
the fact that we we allow
the
and encourage at the highest levels of
government we encourage a roving gangs
of criminals to burn the country down
for eight months at a time in a kind of
ecstatic religious celebration of of a
career criminal who was killed because
he took a fatal drug a amount of illegal
drugs and resisted arrest while
committing a crime
does that make a lot of sense i don't
know i just kind of fear that we're
becoming the baddies
and the democrats are actively
encouraging us to be the baddies and
they're cheering it on and threatening
to line us all up against the wall at
their call to arms
and what are the conservatives doing
we're saying well
you know i can't force my morality on on
anybody
you know i don't listen listen i don't
want to i don't want to force my
religious views on anybody okay i might
not support
10 year old boys being sexually abused
by
by their uh lesbian eunuch guardians and
being trotted out for the sexual
pleasure of depraved people in new york
city i might not support it okay
all right but i will fight to the death
to defend your right to do it no what
are you talking about what do you no no
yeah please impose your morality
you have to
you have to please impose your religious
views that your your crazy extreme
religious view that we shouldn't
sexualize 10 year olds and march them
down the runway and have them dancing
around at bars in the country
for dollar bills which has happened
multiple times now on video
please impose your crazy morality that
says that children should be allowed to
be children and raised with their mother
and father and not not have their
genitals chopped off please i support it
if that's theocracy then sign me up baby
call me the holy roman emperor okay
do we do we have the right to oppose
this stuff anymore i'm not so sure
there's a major case just came out of
yeshiva
university i love yeshiva it's the
jewish university in new york it's it i
think it was the very first school that
i ever spoke at you know i give
lots and lots of campus lectures every
single year by the way i've got my young
americans foundation tours coming up
this fall i i think we're still we might
still be accepting applications for
schools if you want to bring me my tour
there that might be closed but in any
case we'll be announcing the school soon
my very first one years ago was at
yeshiva these kids are super smart very
very you know solidly formed jewish
students
in new york in the kind of belly of the
beast and now
the supreme court has has demanded that
yeshiva university establish an
lgbt
group
now this is a little bit weird
because as you know
judaism is not exactly so supportive of
lgbt
and these kids are
take judaism seriously they take their
religion seriously and they don't want
to just throw it out the window like so
many
modern woke people
and so yeshiva said no we don't want to
establish an
lgbtq club because that violates our
religious views and this is a religious
school
and the supreme court said yeah well too
bad
too bad now
alito
thomas gorsuch and barrett all dissented
they all seem to suggest that yeah the
jewish school has a right to be jewish
and doesn't have to be forced to go
along with the sodom and gomorrah stuff
but
the majority
including roberts including kavanaugh
the majority
goes with the lgbt group and so what
this means is
you don't really have a right to your
religion this this is one of the big
fears with the the gay marriage bill i
mentioned uh yesterday when i was
ranting against dr oz that he came out
and affirmatively said i love that
they're we're going to not only
accept obergefell and the redefinition
of marriage by the supreme court we're
going to actively enshrine it in law and
i'm a republican and i totally support
it so there's no reason for you to
support this
uh it's
i think speaks to a huge lack of
judgment from dr oz but it's not even
just about redefining marriage this is
the crazy part of of the law i was
talking with senator cruz about this
last night
it's not just yeah okay obergefell had
its decision
obergefell is the law of the land
according to the supreme court
what the law
says is that now that this is the
definition of marriage if this passes
then you don't have a right to disagree
with it
and if you continue to oppose this
radical redefinition of marriage
you
what we're going to come after your
school we're going to come after your
business we're going to come after your
nonprofit we're going to come after your
church
okay it is a math it is it is a
criminalization
of holding the view of marriage
that people held for all of human
history until
seven years ago so even if some people
wrote in they say michael you know look
you've gone too far i i support
obergefell or at least i support gay
marriage in principle or or even some
people have written and they say i'm gay
married you know and yeah i think you're
being too harsh about this
let's say
sure okay we have a disagreement on the
nature of marriage okay
that's fine let's say though that you
totally support obergefell you totally
support gay marriage you would vote to
enshrine gay marriage in law in a state
or wherever
do you really support
criminalizing
the
the view
of
virtually everyone everywhere in the
world until five minutes ago that
marriage is between a man and a woman
for the sake of the generation and
education of children
would you support stripping the
tax-exempt status from churches and
charities that disagree with that we
know the administration is going to go
after people
the democrats have already gone after
catholic charities for doing this
for refusing to
to give up the catholic view of sex and
marriage in adoption agencies for
instance they've already sued them it's
already gone up to the high courts you
don't think that they're going to do
that now no that's what this is all
about
it's a
so there's no way out of this to say
well i don't want to impose my views i
don't know you ha
we have to stand for something guys we
have to stand for something or else
we're all going to be just giggling on
the way to the the gulags oh well so
much for the tolerant left yes so much
so much for them there yeah that's right
how funny is that it's gonna be so so
funny when we've got maisie hirono
lining us up in a blindfold with a
cigarette in our mouths the rest of the
show is continuing now you don't want to
miss it this i'm so excited we've got a
great interview with a young lady named
angela
some people have written and they've
asked me about kind of all the weird
the weird kind of demonic stuff like the
kind of weird occult stuff that you're
seeing in the culture you know a top
biden aide wears pentagrams on his chest
that's kind of it's really weird right
so this uh young lady angela ucci was
involved in the occult was involved in
new age spirituality was involved in
astrology it was a pretty prominent
voice on it and then
she realized it was all terrible and
had this kind of road to damascus moment
and is speaking out against it you don't
want to miss it if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
[Music]
[Music]
you